let me ask you out there
question okay so if you think of like
humans on Earth life on Earth as this
pocket of complexity that
emerged you know and there's a bunch of
conditions that came to be and there's
uh darwinian Evolution and however life
originated do you think it's possible
there's some pockets of complexity of
that sort inside dark
matter we can't see so that's possible
MH um I chemistry and biology evolving
in different ways and that's one of the
reasons we suggest I mean it's not the
reason but it would be true if there
were the type of interactions we suggest
I mean it would need more complex ones
and we don't know um I will say that the
conditions that give rise to life and
complexity they're complex they're
unlikely um so it's it's not like
there's great odds that would happen but
there's no reason to know that it
doesn't happen it's worth investigating
are there other forces that exist in the
dark matter sector that's exactly so the
Dark Matter sector doesn't have all the
forces of the the standard model of
physics right as far as we know it
doesn't have any it might have it at
some low level but it could have its own
forces just like Yeah The Dark Matter
might not experience our light maybe it
has its light that we don't experience
so there could be other kinds of forces
I mean there could be other kinds of
forces even within our sector that are
too weak for us to have discovered so
far or that exist at different scales
than we know about I mean we detect what
interacts strongly enough with our
detectors to detect so it's worth asking
and that's one of the reasons we build
big colliders to see are there other
forces other particles that exist say at
higher energies at shorter distance
scales than we've explored so far so
it's not just in the dark matter sector
Even in our sector there could be a
whole bunch of stuff we don't yet
know